Was war das gestern abend für ein emotionales
Ereignis.
Da zitterten die Unterkiefer, Tränen flossen
und unzählige Fists und High Fives wurden
gegeben.
Nach bangen Minuten ist die Marssonde Insight
auf dem roten Planeten gelandet.
Und der Hammer viele von euch und ich sind
jetzt mit dabei auf unserem nächsten Planeten!
Wie das?
Und was sind die ersten Signale vom Lander?
Jetzt in Clicxoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt
es tägklich faszinierende Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Jetzt habe ich etwas Gänsehaut.
Ich gehöre zu den ersten Menschen auf dem
Mars.
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der ein oder
andere daran.
Für diesen siebenmonatigen Flug zu unserem
nächsten Planeten konnte man sich registrieren
und bekam ein Ticket.
Ich hatte damals den Link gepostet.
Wer von euch ist gestern auch mit auf dem
Mars gelandet?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wir alle, beziehungsweise unsere Namen sind
auf einem Mikrochip an Bord der Sonde gespeichert.
Und so sind wir gestern mit erfolgreich auf
dem Mars gelandet.
Die erste erfolgreiche Landung seit sechs
Jahren und die achte Landung überhaupt.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch uns allen!
Das war wirklich gestern richtig emotional.
Die Spannung war zum Zerreissen und nach zahlreichen
Zwischen-Statusmeldungen………. gab es
schließlich den erfolgreichen Touchdown und
wenige Minuten später das erste Foto!
Sieben Minuten dauerte die Landung nur.
Mit einer Geschwindigkeit von 19.888 Kilometern
pro Stunde tauchte die Sonde in die dünne
Marsatmosphäre ein, erhitzte sich dabei auf
1500 Grad Celsius auf und verlor rapide an
Geschwindigkeit, bis schliesslich die Bremsfallschirme
gezündet wurden.
Wir auf der Erde haben das alles acht Minuten
später erfahren, denn so lange dauert es
bis Licht vom Mars zu uns und auch jedes andere
Funksignal bei uns alndet.
Und weitere acht Minuten später kam das erste
Bild zu uns, der Marshorizont ist hinter einer
Menge an Dreck zu erkennen.
Noch war der Staubschutz nicht entfernt.
Der wurde erst nach einiger Zeit abgesprengt,
nachdem sich der Staub, der durch die Landung
aufgewirbelt worden war gelegt hatte.
Und so sah es dann aus.
Dass die Bilder so schnell zu uns gelangt
waren verdanken wir zwei Mars Cube One Satelliten,
die die Daten viel schneller aus dem Marsorbit
zur Erde senden können als der Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter.
Über diese Minisatelliten gelangten dann
die ersten Bilder sehr schnell zur Erde.
Gestartet waren diese beiden Minisatelliten
zusammen mit dem InSight-Lander am 5.
Mai 2018 von der Vandenberg Launch Site in
Kalifornien.
Der Insight Lander, wird sich zum ersten Mal
mit einem vom Deutschen Zentrum für Luft-
Und Raumfahrt gebauten Schlagbohrer bis zu
fünf Meter in den Marsboden bohren soll.
Dieser “Maulwurf” ist Teil des HP3-Experiemnts
an Bord.
Dieses Heat Flow and Physical Properties Package
soll den Wärmefluss des Mars messen und damit
Rückschlüsse auf die Entwicklung des Mars
ermöglichen.
Prof.
Tilman Spohn Projektleiter beim DLR dazu:
“Im Prinzip sind dies zwar einfache Messungen,
aber in der Ausführung sind sie kompliziert."
Der "Maulwurf" des DLR wird Temperatursensoren
Zentimeter für Zentimeter in den Marsboden
bringen.
Heizelemente werden dann den Boden aufheizen
und Sensoren den Wärmefluss messen.
Getestet wurde dies unter anderem am DLR-Institut
für Raumfahrtsysteme in einer meterhohen,
mit Sand gefüllten Röhre.
Ein Radiometer am Instrument überwacht zudem
die Temperatur der Oberfläche am Landeplatz.
Aus beiden Datensätzen - der Messung an der
Oberfläche und im Inneren - können die Wissenschaftler
dann auf den Wärmefluss des Planeten schließen.
"Aus diesen Erkenntnissen lernen wir dann
auch mehr über die Entwicklung unserer Erde."
so Professor Spohn.
Eigentlich sollte die Mission schon im März
2016 starten.
Doch eine Vakuumleck am ersten Hauptexperiement,
dem Seismometer, stoppte den Start.
Mit ihm sollen Erdbeben, die Auswirkungen
von Meteoriteneinschlägen und sonstige Bodenbewegungen
gemessen werden, woraus Rückschlüsse auf
den Aufbau des Mars geschlossen werden können.
Wir könnten also schon bald erfahren, ob
der Kern des Mars noch flüssig oder schon
fest ist.
Wie immer werdet ihr es hier mit als erste
erfahren.
Damit ihr kein Video verpasst, abonniert am
besten auch den englischen Kanal.
Das geht hier.
Denn auch dort gibt es immer mehr Videopremieren.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Mysterious Object
in our Galaxy - Milky Way Mystery Ich freue
mich auch auf dem englischen Kanal zu sehen!
See you soon, stay tuned!